castelfidardo is still famous and known today it
is the central fulcrum of the
accordion
[Music]
my name is marco palmieri I work at
the company sisma realizes it and we make
accordion the history of the
castelfidardo accordion was born in 1863
considering that
16 thousand instruments are currently produced in
castelfidardo  a year like all most
of the castelfidardo company let's say
I'm following let's say in the footsteps of my
father and then I try to carry on
the tradition then this is the last
instrument born in the facebook house it is a
basin under an accordion like this
is  composed of more than 10,000 pieces, the
prices can vary in price,
let's say from the cheapest instrument and
starts at around 2,000 euros
up to a maximum of 12,000
this here we are
about 4 euros this is a
traditional tool for the construction
of  this instrument and 4 months
[Music]
[Applause]
over time have never been changed  ia
introduced by man so let's say a
certain sense we consider ourselves as
masters of artisans who try to
carry on a protection and maybe
not lose it over time it
is an emotion surely to see what it
creates and to see the finished instrument
is a joy is a  to say the hell I did
this on the other side is also a
let's say a joy anyway to see the
musician who plays your instrument and
therefore never knows
[Music]
here it is
no
then
[Music]
[Applause]